i'm not super happy where i am right now
i need to start working on some changes
and i uh one of the things i could do is
i could write a book you know it's
something i've always wanted to do like
why don't why can't i just do it
when did you move to los angeles i moved
to los angeles in 1996.
and why um
i had shot a low-budget independent film
with some friends of mine in new jersey
they they actually already lived in los
angeles
they were people i'd gone to school with
film school with so they one of them
came back to new jersey we shot the
movie and then we came to los angeles to
edit it because another friend of mine
was working in a post house and he could
get us on the avids like you know after
hours at night uh and it was only
supposed to be for six months was you
know was the plan so i came here with
like maybe three grand you know and like
you know and i crashed on sofas and it
ended up taking of course years you know
so i i got had to get a job and you know
the years went by and by the time we
finished the movie i you know had a
whole life out here at that point so i
said well i guess i live in los angeles
now so that was how i ended up here
what was your reality like after a
couple of years that's a tough one i
would say it was probably pretty normal
pretty average i mean i i i got a job at
a small production company and i started
out as a talent manager's assistant
and from that position i sort of you
know worked my way through that company
i don't know if i worked i don't know if
i'd say i worked my way up but i worked
my way to other positions you know in
that company and i eventually wound up
being
in charge of all the
camera equipment production equipment on
a tv show that they launched called a
blind date
which
was very successful for them and went on
for many years and i worked with them
for i'd say like five or six years on
that show
and that kind of led to other you know
other jobs and other career
opportunities and things but mostly on
the behind the scenes side versus the
creative side so
you know while that was always going on
i was always in the background you know
writing or trying to come up with ideas
and stuff like that but most of my work
was more
technical
and so
did you see how if you got like a
regular job on you know reality tv or
whatever you could make a very good
living but
maybe some of the creativity wouldn't be
absolutely in fact i would say
i i could have i think a big part of it
is like believing yourself and like you
know putting yourself out there because
looking back i'm sure i could have had
more creative opportunities if i'd
reached for them but i think i wasn't i
don't think my confidence was super high
at that time
um i do know guys that started off as
you know pas and went on to become
segment producers or story producers
um so i i think absolutely if someone
wants to get into the business like just
you know you have to get your foot in
the door somehow so take you know find a
pa job find an assistant job just get
started you know you never know who
you're going to meet or where it's going
to lead you and i couldn't have
predicted even the path that i took
would not have seemed obvious to me at
the beginning you know so
but then i think you had a i don't know
if you if you get busy living or get
busy dying
yeah that came that actually came much
later you know i mean i was out here for
many years before that and i think
that's kind of what i mean when i say uh
i i don't think i think i i think
everything that i ended up achieving i
probably could have achieved about 10
years earlier than i did if i had been
more confident and if i'd you know
trusted myself and most importantly not
allowed myself to get discouraged
uh and i think you know you hear this a
lot that it's obviously it's a tough
business and there's going to always be
more no's than yeses
but i think it's um you just have to
really understand that prepare for it
and just keep you know keep plugging
away keep trying keep working on your
own things and not don't be shy about
putting yourself out there because i i
think uh that moment you're talking
about came many years later but it could
have come sooner you know in my opinion
when i look back on my life
do you think it was confidence or
playing it safe
probably both you know a little both
um i mean what happened with me was i
think i allowed myself to get uh
discouraged early on because i had uh
like i said we had made this independent
film
we moved out here we finished it
um and the film turned out you know for
what it was it turned out okay we did
sell it actually which is rare but we
certainly didn't make a lot of money off
of it i'm not you know we weren't uh
we couldn't stop working you know it was
a very small deal
uh but
the next thing i worked on was a
screenplay for a uh a horror movie
that you know in my dream at the time
which i to me seemed like a very modest
dream i'm sure it isn't but you know i
really wanted to work with roger corman
he was a hero of mine
and i always loved b movies and monster
movies and horror movies those kinds of
things and so i had written this script
it was a kind of a retro 50s giant bug
movie kind of thing
and it was optioned by producers working
with roger corman
and i was
you know
on top of the world i mean i was like
this is it like this is the way it's
meant to be you know like it's happening
and of course it you know it ended up
just not working out i mean i don't who
knows i think i think roger at that time
had some deal with some german financing
that fell through and you know i never
actually met him in person or anything
like that it was just through these
producers working with him and that
project just you know went away like
most projects do and i think because i
had it because it seemed so perfect and
so exactly what i wanted when it didn't
happen i think that
just took took the wind out of my sails
for a while and it was a long time
before i really started putting myself
out there creatively after that and that
was a mistake you know i should have
just kept at it
i was reading actually read a
a japanese proverb last night that stood
out to me if you uh if you get knocked
down eight times pick yourself up nine
and i think that is the way this
business works for sure
do you know how to say it in japanese no
japanese but not very much okay
what kind of job were you working when
you started writing tokyo black and can
you tell us about your get busy living
or get busy dying sure i mean first of
all to be clear it wasn't the
the type of job that was so bad it just
wasn't you know where i was wasn't a
good fit for me i was doing uh
post-production sales which i had done
before at other places
and i i i enjoy post-production work
like i mentioned i still do some
post-supervising freelance but just this
particular place and the particular you
know mix of people and and
clients and everything it just wasn't a
good fit for me where i was and i wasn't
very happy there uh i had also gone
through a divorce fairly recently at
that point
um and uh i had always wanted to write a
book
and i'd tried too many times you know i
probably had four or five like
unfinished novels laying around
and uh
i just decided i don't know what it was
but one night i was like well you know
i'm not super happy where i am right now
i need to start working on some changes
and
i uh one of the things i could do is i
could write a book you know it's
something i've always wanted to do like
why don't why can't i just do it
and i had taken a trip to uh japan
not super
it was probably made like five years or
so before that point but i really
enjoyed it and uh i really wanted to go
back but it just for timing and money
and work and everything i just couldn't
do it
and i thought well i could write a book
set in japan and that would sort of be a
mental vacation you know i could kind of
go there mentally
uh and so i was like well what kind of
book would i could i write there and spy
thrower just seemed to kind of go with
that location really well you know like
tokyo and you know think neon lights and
secret agents and spy stuff and uh so i
just sat up this one night
and uh honestly
almost everything from that book came
from this one night of brainstorming
where i just it was like a flash of
inspiration
i mean even even the title you know i
mean it all i i was just like okay it'll
be about this guy what's his name thomas
kane and you know what's it called tokyo
black what is tokyo black and so all
that brainstorming
really almost all of it made it into the
book in the end and that was where that
started
however i didn't finish it around that
time i'd say i got about halfway
and kind of lost steam you know it was
i'd never finished a novel and i it's
you know it's a tough undertaking until
you've done it um a few times
but a few years later
i was working at a place that i really
enjoyed working at things were great
and i had a uh a new girlfriend and she
was over at my apartment and i don't
remember if she wanted to read something
i wrote or if it was just sitting around
but somehow she started reading the
first half of this manuscript that was
like on my desk
and she got really into it and you know
of course she's not an unbiased opinion
so at first i didn't take it too
seriously but she would keep asking me
questions about it like well you know
what's going to happen to this character
or like is is this guy really the bad
guy and like she seemed really invested
in it and that sort of got me to see it
you know in a new light because i think
when you're writing
i mean when you're writing anything but
especially a novel which is the
sprawling thing that's going to take a
long time to finish it's really hard to
assess
your work you know like is it good is it
bad and just even more so in a rough
draft you know so i had really didn't
know in my head like
what this was or what it could be you
know but seeing someone else read it and
get invested in it kind of lit the fire
again
and so that job was a freelance job i
knew it was coming to an end and i also
knew i had another job with those same
people
in about
two or three months you know like they
were booked back to back
so i knew i had this gap and i said well
you know i know i have this two or three
month gap and i know where my money is
coming from you know for the rest of the
year so why don't i see if i can finish
this book
and i'd say that was the point where i
really got serious about writing where i
like made it a scheduled thing and i
would sit down at 9 00 a.m and work
until lunch and you know i would keep a
word count and uh i didn't finish it but
i came pretty i say i knocked off
another quarter and that experience of
working in that way
was very transformative for me i was
like oh i can do this you know i can
actually
fit i can figure out how to fit this in
and even if i have a job if i set aside
this time here i can write this many
words
and so when that second job finished i
went back to the writing i finished up
the book and uh
yeah
that was the start of it all
how many pages had you written when you
kind of
shelved it for a little while um it was
about half the manuscript so i would say
uh you know in in novels versus
screenplays you really think more on
word count than in pages because the
page
is totally dependent on you know
formatting and font size and all that so
i must have been the book was about 85
000 words so i must have been around the
30 to 40 000 you know word mark at that
point so it was enough that you could
kind of start to get a sense of the
story you know and
and kind of get the flow of it and where
it was going because that you know
that's what led her to i think start
asking all those questions you know an
unfinished story is i think
if you're on the right track anyway it's
like you know it's like it's like a itch
you know you just have to know like well
where's this going or what's going to
happen to this person you know
and when you sat down that one night
where you kind of had this
dark night of the soul that i've got to
do something and port it out
was this just an outline on your
computer or like a it wasn't even an
outline yet i would say it was uh just
notes you know just random notes um
you know i knew i wanted it to be set in
japan and i wanted to be a spy thriller
um i you know there's
in the spy throw a lot of spy thrower
authors in that community are
ex-military or ex you know spies and i
know i didn't have that background so i
said okay well i'll make him a guy who
was betrayed and he's on the outside and
then i don't need to know as much about
the inner workings you know these
agencies
little things like that you know and i
knew
i knew
some of the locations and some of the
characters but i wouldn't call it an
outline it was more like about a couple
pages of just random notes
and then i started making an outline you
know from that point on
so you wanted to make him sort of this
fringe outcast character i did for for
multiple reasons a for the reason i said
because i thought
i thought i could do a better job with
that
and also i'm just always drawn to sort
of outsider characters you know i mean
in star wars my favorite character is
han solo not luke skywalker you know um
but also i think i you know i did put a
lot of thought into it i'm a big james
bond fan and when i i don't just mean
the movies i mean the original books by
ian fleming i've read them all many
times
and so i tried to think sort of of what
fleming did you know because those books
were written after world war ii when
britain's influence was kind of fading
i don't know this may be really boring
but
but uh you know i think he created a
hero that fit what england
wanted at the time you know they wanted
to feel
important in the grand scheme of things
even though their
kind of old world was gone at that point
you know and their influence was
diminishing so he created this epitome
of an english hero british hero you know
he's sort of middle class he has money
but he's not a snob you know he's right
in that spot
um you know he's very patriotic to queen
and country but he's also very well
traveled at a time when many people
weren't well traveled you know most
people did not get to leave the country
back then
so uh so i kind of looked at what he did
and i thought to myself well what what
does that look like for america now you
know in this time period and to me i
think
americans are you know we're marked by
rebelliousness and we are more outsiders
and our our patriot at least my
patriotism is more sort of
you know a little bit cynical we've gone
through some things you know that that
makes it hard to just sort of take all
that stuff on face value so i just tried
to go through that same process of what
would
not just taking like that kind of
character and making him american but
going through that thought process of
what would an american hero and that
mold be you know that was how i came up
with a lot of it
you